we have some really big news today in
regards to the future of spider-man
films in the MCU we have a little more
clarification on the direction that
Marvel and Sony want to take spider-man
and the good news is this information is
coming directly from Sony how's it going
everybody it's Warren and everybody is
super excited that spider-man is back in
the MCU the Disney Sony deal is done
spider-man is finally home but what is
next for our favorite website well ever
since the sony disney deal has come to a
completion we are finding out a lot more
information about what the future holds
for spider-man we already have a date
for spider-man 3 and we know that
spider-man is going to appear in at
least one other MCU film in the future
as well well today it seems like we have
gotten a lot of information about what
this next spider-man film could be and
what the future spider-man film could be
in the MCU as well including main
villains and crossovers from the Sony
universe into the MCU
so we're gonna talk about all that has
been revealed for these future
spider-man films all the villains that
are coming and the crossover with the
Sony verse and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but a quick reminder to
subscribe to my channel and hit that
notifications bell I'm doing a giveaway
giving away an Xbox one or a ps4 winners
choice I'm picking a winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
all you have to do to enter is be
subscribed to my channel leave a comment
below and hit that like button so like I
said big news today about spider-man's
feature and it comes directly from Amy
peskow now if you're not familiar with
who Amy Pascal is she was the
chairperson for Sony Pictures
Entertainment she now owns her own
production company where she produced
many films including spider-man
homecoming and she is going to be
producing the next spider-man film
spider-man 3 this was part of the
agreement that Sony and Disney worked
out when they decided that spider-man
can remain in the MCU and in a recent
featurette that Sony put out about
spider-man far from home Amy Pascal
pointed out all of the villains that
have been introduced in the MCU and when
she was talking about these villains she
said and I quote these villains we now
have in our universe happened to be the
characters that are in the sinister six
there may be something that happens with
that end quote
so Amy Pascal just dropped a pretty big
bomb hinting that the sinister six will
be coming soon this is something that
has been
talked about for a very long time and
even before spider-man far from home
came out there were some people that
said they saw an early screening of it
in which they introduced Oscorp now this
would make sense because it will most
likely be Norman Osborn who puts
together the sinister six and right now
in the MCU as far as villains are
concerned we have vulture shocker tinker
and scorpion and not to mention that a
lot of people don't think Mysterio is
really dead
and if Mysterio really is in fact alive
Norman Osborn would be the sixth member
of the sinister six
but if Mysterio isn't alive we know that
Sony has been wanted to introduce Kraven
for some time now so the path for
spider-man in his next film or his next
two films has been laid out we know that
his next film is going to be spider-man
3 and is just going to be a solo
spider-man film but we don't know what
the movie after that is going to be we
don't know if it's going to be another
solo spider-man film or if it's going to
be another team-up film like Captain
America Civil War or one of the Avengers
films but the great news is that Amy
Pascal who is producing the next
spider-man film has mentioned the
sinister six
so if spider-man 3 doesn't introduce
them it's going to start to build up the
sinister six to be introduced in the
next spider-man film which is great news
because I know that we have all wanted
to see them in the MCU for a really
really long time there was hope that we
would see them in spider-man far from
home but of course that didn't happen
and then it seemed like all hope was
lost after Sony pulled spider-man out of
the MCU but hope is restored
spider-man is back and producer Amy
Pascal has hinted that we are going to
be getting the sinister six in the near
future so let me know what you think
about this I know before spider-man far
from home came out a lot of you were
saying that you really wanted to see the
sinister six in the MCU and now it
appears that it is finally happening so
let me know how you feel about it but
let me know if you think Mysterio is
still alive or not do you think he died
and spider-man far from home be sure to
drop a comment down below and also
subscribe to my channel and like this
video so you can enter my giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU don't forget to follow me on
Twitter and Instagram and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof